hello welcome to big moon it's us three
today we got a Nicki TIFF and Jess we're
continuing to rotate girls because we
realize what we have like four or five
girls on just a lot of talking over each
other yeah so we've been doing three
lately and maybe we'll pop in the guest
of two but today we wanted to talk about
interior decorating because not only
have a lot of you requested this topic
as like people that argue maybe you're
just moving out of your parents house
getting your own apartment or maybe you
just moved into a brand new place and
you don't know where to start
but also all three of us have that in
common
where we actually like decorating we
love it
yeah look tips new place I got I got two
she showed me a [ __ ] FaceTime tour of
the whole place looks do I live on the
outside all your wallpapers oh girl I
brought my wallpapers here front and
center to show not that I can't wait so
jess and you just moved into your own
place like a few months ago and it
already looks poppin I always forget
that you just moved in because like it
already looks so good yeah so fast
yeah actually your balcony is so cute
you should ask photos of it I don't know
I do sometimes I show little bits of it
I just kind of don't want to post too
much to where people can figure out
where I live I guess I make sense yeah I
don't know I'm just kind of because I
live in kind of a famous apartment
complex
oh damn flag blue if you lived in LA in
the last like 10 or 15 years you might
know it you know so I'm just like oh
don't nobody figure out where I'm at
yeah stop dropping clues Jess yeah
Jessica thank you yeah so this is
actually this is my office
and this was painted before we moved in
and this is my least favorite wall of
the entire [ __ ] house because they
painted these stripes crooked they're
like oh it like wobble it's dry but yeah
they posted these stripes leave
I think the person that was painting got
really carried away with these like
stripes because they were callin oh yeah
I mean it would be cool if it was a
column that's true it did I think
they're like oh yeah how it like in my
place how it kind of like oh right yeah
I don't want to be way cooler if it was
cool but now I can see that it's crooked
that you pointed it out so I'm gonna I
didn't know is this [ __ ] out of me it's
look but I don't repaint it because this
will eventually be a nursery okay I
don't want to like make a decision and
then change it when like a baby was here
so yeah that's been one of this but I
wanted to start with like where did you
guys start like when you like tip you
just moved in isn't it overwhelming
warehouse your process how did you
[ __ ] just start decorating oh yes I
mean I did briefly talk about it in a
previous podcast but for me like I think
I just had to decide on a color palette
that I really liked and when I just at
that point it was really hard for me to
make a decision so I was like you know
what I want to be like loud colors like
loud patterns I wanted to be very
vibrant I the one decision I definitely
did make from the beginning was that I
want like every single my place that I
look inside my house like every view
every room I wanted to make me feel
really happy and I want it to be really
like colorful because color ends up like
giving you a dopamine in your brain so
I'm like I just I want it to be vibrant
that's why for me personally my bedroom
is actually my least favorite room in
the whole house because it's very like
neutral tropical which is still like
it's nice because it's very calming so
that's okay but yeah I'm still working
on the bedroom but every other place in
my in the house is just full of color
like my most favorite piece in the whole
place is the new couch that I got oh
yeah we beautiful like teal like velvety
kind of couch which is your hair but it
does actually um but
freaking cat just started pooping on it
why no way hello
like resample days yeah oh no your cats
mad at you for something what are you
doing wrong no so I told ok so the way
we split up cat duties is that I'm
responsible for like the feeding we take
like the food in the water I need to
like make sure that the fountain is good
and then Casey handles the like the
kitty litter stuff and he'll like we use
these pellets and so he'll go like
months without changing the pellets
you're supposed to change it like every
month or a month and a half and I'm like
seeds Oh is pooping on our couch because
you're not changing the [ __ ] pellet
Belarus and like I have got like I don't
know man that couch
I [ __ ] love so much obviously I love
my cat a lot but I got so pissed where I
told Casey I'm like I will get rid of
this [ __ ] cat I think is so lucky
he's potty-trained yeah girl he's lucky
no just kidding but yeah like that's the
thing that I'm like come on man way to
couch but anyway back to interior design
so I I knew that I need like the type of
couch I wanted to get to because my
house is so small like it's very like I
need a specific kind of furnishing to
make it work like make the flow work so
once I figured out that I wanted an L
couch then I was like cool now we get to
move to the colors and because I picked
teal for the backsplash of the kitchen
which is like in the same area of the
living room
I'm like let's tie it in like it's a lot
of like tiny tying things in from one
piece that I start with and then I move
on to the next and it's just like things
that I like that I'm drawn to that like
I said is very colorful and vibrant and
make me happy though ah process is
awesome I had a similar kind of thing
when I was decorating so I picked like a
dark blue or just any types of blue and
then also gold were my accents so like I
just made sure that a lot of things tied
into that and I feel like that's a way
that you can actually use a ton of
different textures a ton of different
like like like different woods or
or different types of fabrics or any
materials like you can use so many
different things and bring them together
you don't have to do that matchy-matchy
stuff that people kind of did in the 90s
in 2000 yeah yeah you can use all kinds
of different textures from like a metal
table to like a wood coffee table to
then like a different style of a
bookcase or something like you can mix
so many different things together if you
just have like either a texture or a
color that ties them in together in
different ways even in small ways so
that's what I did
so even that gets super overwhelming for
me where I'm like well where do I start
like what texture copy yeah like what
kind of wood what color can I use of the
way that I like originally started
started when I first moved into my very
first apartment it was like blank white
like very standard apartment a plain
colored floor like carpet and I need
like I needed it to feel like a home
because I got anxiety that I wasn't
living with my parents anymore and I
just wanted to feel like I was at home
when I came home and the only way to do
that was to make sure everything was
super decorated and so I actually
stumbled I started looking into function
and I I stumbled across this book called
move your stuff change your life and it
was like basically a dummies guide to
function so not claiming to be a
function X pert but it helped me at
least make these like structured
decisions because I tend to thrive when
there's like a set of rules and then you
can be creative within those rules so it
it kind of has you set it up in a way
we're like Fung Shui is about like
making the energy move through your
space freely and so when you come in it
feels like a breath of like fresh air
rather than like everything is stuffy
and stuff so the number one rule of Fung
Shui is to keep everything clutter free
but then within that there's like
different elements of like there is fire
water wood metal and earth those are the
five elements in your house and then you
have like it represents different things
like fire represents reputation and
respected like purple is like money so
it's very
into like my closet no like how many
things are functioning that I
accidentally did all right yeah you know
do you know couple of things like I I
kind of want to see yeah did I do that
okay so everybody listening right now
including you guys when you walk in
through your front door think of it as a
grid that split up into nine sections so
like three three three
so like grid your house that way your
front door is like the you know most
southern point overlook if it was a
compass you know so then when you're at
your front door the very far back wall
like the farthest wall back whether
that's a room or whether that's a living
room or whatever that is the farthest
wall back from you um that is your fire
area so things in that area would be
like bright lights you would want like
if the fireplace would be awesome um a
TV also is like lit up candles anything
that's like fire oriented also the
helpful element for fire is wood so
anything that's like tree like that's
your respect fame um
yeah like you're basically a reputation
corner so is this bad yeah it's been a
little on fire but yeah so it everything
that what do you think fire in your mind
like that kind of thing so red is a good
color for that area and then anything
that's like green or brown that
represents wood that could feed the fire
also pointy things so the shape for that
area is a triangle
so anything triangular um about to
perfect and then cacti are actually
really good in that area they're not
very good for any other area in the
house but a cactus works really well in
that specific area cactus but I do have
succulents so I'm close okay yeah that
works too um and then similarly a symbol
similarily
similarly yeah
there is also an opposing element that
would put out that fire so you don't
want any water elements in that area you
don't want any fountains aquariums
anything that's where I have a fountain
oh all is my my like directly across
from the front door is the garage door
but like up against that wall is where I
have my stove in the microwave and like
so it's like the kitchen oh yeah yeah
they're water fountains the cat fountain
movies yeah that fountain yeah but it
actually like the closest to like when
you open the front door that wall is
your water section and that represents
career so anything that represents water
which is like black is the color for
that section mirrors
undulating shapes like this yeah
mirrors are great for that area black
against my farthest like where my belt
so like my front door is the
southernmost point and then I guess the
furthest thing is my balcony and I do
have a black thing that runs along the
the balcony is your balcony under a roof
yes okay I think it might still count
thing but I don't know the specifics but
you can also I got so many other points
that I just washed that one okay okay
just like that one a lot higher around
and put a lot of fire nitrogen there's a
lot of wood there's a lot of triangles
there's a lot of other [ __ ] okay now
also when you're looking at that wall if
you look to the right of it that that
corner right there that's your love
corner that's your romance corner so
anything with like any candles there
like anything that sparks romance like
curfew like certain scents flowers power
plant or anything that reminds Alex
that's fine anything never mind you I do
like that I have a I have a round
feather lamp that hangs from the ceiling
so it's almost perfect that's kind of
cute right just like a ball that drops
from Center amount of feathers and I got
that because I was like okay if I remove
in with a guy I'm never going to get the
chance of a [ __ ] like round
feather hanging lamp in my living room
ever again so I'm gonna do this while I
have this girly space yeah so also you
want to make sure not to have anything
that that would ruin that element so
nothing like like don't put your kitty
litter in the love corner because that's
loopy the shitty love life that corner
is where my sink is and like rice and
knives and it's kitchen it's a kiddy
nice that's right keep my knives in that
corner um yeah I know so saw like this
was all just a fun like structuring
thing like it's the rules aren't like
hardcore but if say I was like oh no
like I'm running out of money or like
there's something I need I can't I'm
having trouble paying my bills I would
look at that area and then try to
improve that area like with decorations
for that element and you know placebo
wise we need what you focus on grows
things would change like I would start
manifesting more money or you know more
love or whatever it is so I found that
really interesting and I started with
that baseline and the most important
part is attention and making sure you
feel good about the stuff that you're
putting in space but that was like my
starting point and then from there
deciding on the style have you guys ever
taken any of those style tests that are
like yeah it's your interior what's your
interior design styles um my most weight
it was it was modern modern bohemian or
something that's lying like that
yeah hey I don't know what mine is I
think you're just like mid-century some
of it contemporary can you guys tell me
like so we've got some I actually hung
up Christmas lights such a cute yeah it
looks cute at night and then I did not
like so I don't know I mean it's just
like a [ __ ] of things I don't
know it's like a modern Glanton well it
is yeah so did you use a lot of blush
pink and especially in your bedroom and
stuff oh yeah my bunion a chair my
bedrooms way different from the living
room that's for sure it's like all pink
you can get white that's great bedrooms
that's romantic she'd be that one
good energy yeah so but if you don't
know your style you can either take a
style quiz online there's tons of style
quizzes or what I found really really
helpful is to go through like Instagram
the Instagram explorer page you can look
up like once you start looking at one
home decor like interior design page it
starts suggesting all these other ones
on the explore page sure and I just
started saving like in the save folder
um like different like the ones that
inspired me the most and not really
thinking about it style at all just like
if I liked that room I would save it and
then later went back scrolling through
that folder and noticed like
similarities so even if I picked
completely different styles because my
problem at first was that I was too
eclectic like I couldn't just pick one
style because I like so many different
kinds but there were certain elements
that I found in each saved post that I
was like oh I really like mid-century
modern decor like the furniture pieces
at least so buying the big furniture
items are all mid-century modern looking
and then um moving on from there you
know you can find different types of
accents like bohemian accents but I
noticed it did a lot for my headspace
and you know what else does a lot for
your headspace
yes a talk space is great because it's
an online therapy and especially for
Mental Health Awareness Month did you
guys know that we're a mental health
awareness I guess that's right
exactly now I'm aware oh there we go
yeah so so talk spaces online therapy
and they're more committed than ever to
expanding the access to support anyone
who's struggling particularly in this
month and obviously during this time
like this is like strangest time ever so
it's the best time for you to actually
reach out to a therapist so you can so
what they do is that they have licensed
therapists and you can contact them from
the safety of your own home so you don't
go anywhere you can reach out from your
device whenever something's on your mind
so you can send your therapist
text an audio message picture or even a
video message and you can send this 24/7
as much as you need to but you do have
to make appointments to actually like be
like one on one and stuff so talk space
matches you with a licensed therapist
based on your needs and your preferences
they have thousands of licensed
therapists trained in over 40
specialties including anxiety depression
and relationship issues so once you're
matched you begin therapy that very same
day so bottom line you deserve support
and don't have to struggle on your own
your talk space therapist can be your
dedicated support system they're there
to help you feel healthier and more
empowered even in these uncertain
circumstances so as a listener of this
podcast you can get $100 off your first
month on talk space to match with your
perfect therapist go to talk space calm
or download the app make sure to use a
code mood and to get $100 off your first
month and show your support for the show
that's mood mo OD and talk space comm I
love it you guys want to know what else
I love what do you love Jess this is my
favorite this is absolutely my favorite
shampoo and conditioner that I've used
this is function of beauty I reordered
this now this is only my first time
reordering because the first time I got
it lasted me six months or more I think
I came to remember lasted a long time
but I honestly love this if you take a
little quiz online you put in like
issues that you're having with your hair
and then they formulate they make a
specific shampoo and conditioner for you
I had and they also save it like I have
a certain formulas done last time but
this time I tweaked it just a little bit
I actually got a sense because last time
I chose unscented more of the
conditioner and this time I got the
peach scent I I think I might need
trying the different scents every time
and I love that it's like it's still the
same formula the same conditioner for my
hair but I can just like I can make it
smell different or I can make it a
different color if I want but because I
have blonde
I don't color the conditioner but I do
use a purple shampoo and my hair
honestly I think my hair has been really
like true and honest I think my hair is
done really well with the shampoo and
conditioner with a bleached hair that I
have I haven't really lost a lot of hair
I haven't like my hair has been super
healthy super soft I expected it to be
way worse when I started my bleaching
activities a year ago but my hair has
actually been doing really well and I
think but function of beauty has helped
that a lot this is the Internet's
top-rated customized haircare brand with
over 30,000 five-star customer reviews
for curly or straight natural or
processed hair they individually
formulate every bottle based on your
unique hair type style preferences and
hair goals the it's vegan and cruelty
free they never use sulfates parabens
phthalates mineral oils or any other
harmful ingredients I absolutely love
this stuff so to get started right now
goats a function of beauty calm / big
mood to take your 4 part hair profile
quiz and save 20% on your first order
don't spend another minute in hair
misery go to function of beauty calm /
big mood to let them know we sent you
that's function of beauty calm / big
move let them know hey I love that
shampoo conditioner holy absolutely so
good so good yeah yeah I got the
mentholated one so it like tingles my
hair but anyway back to interior
decorating another like I feel like when
you start out you like pick up tips and
tricks and then you like learn as you go
like you learned through failure because
I would I would pick up certain things
and it was always like oh I really like
this desk or this couch or whatever but
then it didn't like it cohesively
together and so like learning about the
color thing like Jess was talking about
earlier of just like at least having an
accent color that runs through
everything
or like Tiff's had her couch match the
backsplash that really helps hides room
together as well as like the style that
I was mentioning right before the break
where like once you I didn't really I
didn't know that there were certain like
your decorating styles I just kind of
would pick out what I liked before but
yeah if you can find similar pieces and
just like mix one or two styles together
that really helps and then if you're
what you're depending on what your
layout is in your house if you have like
more of an open layout you would want
the style to kind of be the same
throughout the house so that it doesn't
like clash with each other
but if you have like how TIFF and I have
like um you know different rooms are
like they're very separated you can
actually do a different style in every
room as long as that particular room
comes together which is really exciting
man cuz you're saying like before the
break you were talking about like
following certain Instagram accounts and
stuff you if you look at all the
different interior design kind of
accounts that I follow my house doesn't
look like any of them like you're always
in like I'm so drawn like a visual lead
to like be like oh this is like entire
creation of this one room it just looks
so great i I can't recreate that though
in my own house that's right like for me
I think that's why it doesn't some
people might say it doesn't really look
very cohesive because it's like kind of
like all over the place for some
people's eyes but um if you can get an
example and like follow like that like
based off of how you like it might
create that yourself kudos to you
because like you Nikki for example like
you and Jess you have both created your
spaces to look like freakin Instagram
friendly like it's so pretty and like so
cohesive and like so like in like
particular kind of style like or two
styles um I don't know how to do that
though I feel like your aim is that well
I especially you're downstairs like from
your living room to your kitchen like
that is so like cohesive and so well put
together it's so Instagram friendly it's
like you realize how much you're
downstairs that first opening that is is
exactly that yeah especially a little
touches a I saw that you put like faces
like those red faces in the opening I
never would have thought that and like
the way
matches against the green plants and
then how it contrasts with the the blue
couch like looks really it looks like
what you're wearing right now yeah but
you know for me the like I guess like
you have to close to it or whatever but
like I end up seeing the completed thing
in my home that I feel like oh [ __ ] this
is this accidentally kind of match like
it actually worked but that's why I was
stressing earlier how like I just really
go with one thing that I really love and
then move to another thing that I really
love and I'm like oh [ __ ] this
accidentally like that's what I said I
did I didn't start with a picture of
anything I never looked at Pinterest I
don't use the Instagram account I don't
do any of that I literally just found a
couple things that I liked on Amazon or
Wayfarer and I was like okay this
inspires this type of feel and then I
just went around it like I somehow I
guess it maybe I picked it up in life
but I literally didn't copy anything and
and also it's really hard to have like a
small budget too because those Instagram
accounts those are like that's like a
$5000 bed and they don't you know them
so like it's hard to follow those as
example I'm not even talking about
copying them so for me I used to do it
that way where it was just more like
piece by piece and glue along the room
but then um yeah like at the end of the
day I when I would take a picture I'm
like how come it doesn't match like like
what I'm seeing then the the feeling
doesn't translate to like when I'm
taking a picture of it or when I like
video ain't and then so from those
Instagram pictures that I saved I
noticed like certain elements in each
picture now like not coughing like
directly somebody is yeah thing but like
I noticed all of them were filled with
plants specifically like certain types
of plants like mongst arrows or you know
and then I started getting into plants
so I just for a while I just became
obsessed with plants because that for in
particular was a common thread
throughout all of those Instagram posts
what no matter what style they had like
whether it was modern or bohemian or
whatever so they exact and then I guess
that kind of like when you're talking
about one thing going into the next I
was like okay the plants thing really
did make a huge difference because now I
like really like this room even though
all I changed
were plants and then it was like I
noticed certain colors of wood I really
liked with those plants so like walnut
for example I really really freaked
for some reason that particular wood
looks really really good against the
plants that I was looking at and then
later as I was redoing my bedroom and I
was trying to decide like what do I want
the bedroom to look like like what's the
feeling I want
I noticed that like I had bookmarked a
lot of black accent walls so like
alright we're just gonna go bulls we're
just gonna make like this well the black
accent wall I've never done that before
yeah that's a big deal it's a huge like
difference I would never won't get a
wall black before yeah
if I hadn't seen with my own eyeballs
that other people have done it multiple
times in different types of rooms and it
looks really good I probably wouldn't
have tried it like I wouldn't have tried
that not something that I would normally
gravitate towards or like think that
would look good and I thought that it
would suck the light out of a room and
make it really dark in there but it
actually brightened it up because I used
a semi glossy finish and so that yeah
and because it's across from a window it
actually bounces the sunlight on so it
was just like it it enhanced the whole
thing where it looks more like a hotel
sort of vibe now and I really really
liked it I don't think I would have
taken a risk like that if I had it like
saved all those also you own that Rose
too because like if you're that
apartment and you do a black accent wall
they're gonna [ __ ] you up get your like
to repaint this you can get your dilly
stick go do it if you read out loud like
the peel and stick stuff though like I
got all my wallpaper is peeling stick
which is perfect you can see your
wallpapers tip like you're above all of
your wallpaper
okay guys have to watch this episode I
love wallpapers because they're so
freakin fun like oh okay
so the Arkham on the first the first
wallpaper I'm going to show you guys is
from a master bathroom this is what it
looks like
looks so good with the tub in front of
it - yeah I know right wait
you yeah I know it looks I freaking love
it and I also hung up like this
this wooden shelf thingy foreign towels
and stuff it looks really pretty I don't
know if the cat camera can really
capture it but it's like this light like
teal this is really nicely and the
pattern itself this was an accident but
it actually matches my bath rug so that
my bathroom how did you get examined
today that was an accident
any dude on purpose but so this bath rug
I bought four of them because of the
fact that like we have a double sink and
also like like the opposite from the
sink is a shower in the bathtub so I'm
like look we need we need this whole
area to just be covering so I ended up
buying four of these from Urban
Outfitters and they're super cute but
yeah like I said like I didn't it was an
accident the freaking design kind of
matches and so yeah that's the first one
and it's peel and stick and whole legal
for those for people that don't know
what's what's peel and stick what does
that entail is it literally you just
like peel it and stick it like a fit and
how you get a nominal you just take it
out like you just peel it off so the
difference between this and traditional
wall paper is that with traditional
wallpaper you need to have a paste and
you actually have like like paste it on
the the actual paper and like you have
to cut like specific strips of it and
it's like [ __ ] messy and also to
remove it is a pain in the ass maybe a
private resulted to do like traditional
wallpaper Wow so I mean it kind of like
there's a the what the hell am i try say
so there's like good and bad to peel and
stick but good is the fact that it's
easier and it doesn't Daniels you
Hannibal exactly but the bad is that
there's way less design options than
traditional wallpaper clear was this
other wallpaper for my downstairs
bathroom that I want like a completely
fell in love with but it was only
available for it the traditional
wallpaper which I was not trying to mess
around with the taste and stuff but
instead of that I ended up going with
this was he where everyone
love this that like [ __ ] yeah thank you
yeah it's like a chevron and but I love
how they they're both looks like
watercolors yeah they're both the same
colors but then they look like the same
type of saturation because it's like
watercolor yeah and also this is design
is very forgiving because this is
actually the very first wallpaper not
including my stairs but on the actual
wall this one was the first one that I
put up and like what I ended up learning
is that for some reason no matter how
straight you want to go down like for me
at least the wallpaper kept like leaning
away from the left so like it was going
more towards no right so I'm like [ __ ]
so actually I had like strips of wall
showing but at least this pattern very
forgiving so you can tip if you're
trying to do this is order wave more
wallpaper than you need because the
because of the fact that you need to
account for for you matching with the
pattern for the other strip which the
first time I did this I didn't take that
into consideration I just measured out
the wall that I needed and I'll die cool
two rolls that will do but no I actually
needed three rolls because of the like
matching issues yeah yeah exactly but
that isn't the reason why I picked that
wallpaper too is because there's
downstairs bathroom is in that same area
as like my living room the dining room
in the kitchen it's like really really
oh that's perfect and that color and so
like exactly so then I was trying to
match it to like the couch and the
backsplash of the kitchen so I get all
kind of like tied in somehow so that's
for the dumpsters back room and then for
the laundry room just this room is still
not done but this is the wallpaper I
picked for the laundry room I love it
it's like lemony your main Helen in the
tree Jewish yeah you know I was actually
about to get a lemon wallpaper boom like
nah that's too like I don't know it was
to Dina's overlook you yeah I was like a
little too much but I did want yellow
for the laundry room so I ended up
picking this it's like she's yellow
flower it kind of like
delineate the difference between the
downstairs and the upstairs because like
if you see how you kind of have this
tropical or more plant theme like that
ties in with the living the laundry room
which is also upstairs which is more
it's kind of like plant-based it's like
very basic plant but anyway so then but
downstairs you have like a ton of
textures it's like non natural color is
temporary so it's like it's funny how I
don't think you meant to do that but
like yo James is like completely
different from the downstairs but in a
way that works yeah that's true because
yeah like right outside this door here
it's like the little loft area that we
have and I have this like oh just like
this thing which is a tapestry I had
like this tapestry that's like a floral
tapestry too and that and then I kind of
like I like tying that floral miss with
the wallpaper that I chose for the
stairs which like what you're heading up
this oh yeah right you're going to be on
Google's own how did you get the idea to
put wallpaper on the stairs because I've
never seen that and I know you said you
got a little bit of blowback from your
audience yeah well I think I mentioned
it before but I mean it's okay I'm even
mentioned it on my own blog too but I
just talked about how like oh you know
so excited to share my stairs so I ended
up looking at the comments a little bit
that was like the most polarizing thing
on my channel ever we're like half of
the people absolutely loved it and the
other half absolutely hate it and they
were like this is so tacky it's so
grandma ish and the other people are
like oh my god it's so fun and vibrant
and inviting and like it's just so funny
how insanely polarizing the opinions
were yeah no I know and then that is
your survival money section of your home
and it represents family and you used
green it's green is the color for that
area
okay so there's like wood stairs with
green leaves corner is in great thumbs
your fan
since I was so subjective honestly I bet
if you went into the homes of people who
were talking [ __ ] they'd have a basic
ass-kicking couch with a dirty ass rug
and they probably 14 baby and they live
it I really feel like we're really young
yeah exactly like I honestly feel like a
lot of people especially what like
people saying how tacky it was and stuff
I'm like I just got this sense of like
they're just so young either that thing
you're like young and they don't
understand like whatever but or that
they're just so conditioned to seeing
the style that is really trending right
now which is super simplistic yeah we're
natural very very very very very fair
it's very like sophisticated I think it
looks really nice because I follow a lot
of a lot of pages that have that
specific style where it's like really
clean and like neutral colors and that's
like a hold aesthetic there which is I
like I said like I admire that and I
like it a lot but I just didn't want
that in my house yeah it's okay
it's your house like you don't have to
follow that what's trending in seven
also what I don't like about following
what's trending and that's cool it's
that's your things like you're super
into interior decorating like awesome
[ __ ] go off mega mattoon it's
constantly updating her house and I
think that's so inspiring and I love it
cuz I love seeing her new designs each
time but yeah if you're not if you're
just like you know I want to just make
my place look like what's happy those
those trends go out of style like every
every other year every year all ooh and
so if you don't like changing your house
a lot your house gonna be outdated every
[ __ ] so definitely go with what you
like on an evergreen type of way and
then I guess I kind of update like once
every five years like I'll change a room
or whatever or add something new but
yeah I mostly I'm too lazy to do I
really don't [ __ ] lately it's really
exciting it's very expensive but like
during my childhood my mom she was
really into interior design stuff and
like her taste was way
like that like early 2000s I'm like
fancy ish like lots of like tassels and
burgundy and like cream colors like that
was her style and so I like she this
woman was crazy she would like I would
go to Mexico for the summer and then
come back and the entire house is
different it could be not necessarily
new items but she rearranges things like
crazy actually couldn't like stay in
like the way that her house is actually
constantly yes you're like reorganize
everything I'm like I can't do that like
I just this is like this literally is
the exact same layout I have from my
previous house yeah nothing has changed
but yeah I'm too [ __ ] lazy I guess
and that's like this whole thing it's
like this whole project of like fixing
up our first home I'm like this is
awesome
like I'm not gonna touch it until we
move out like or like I'm updating
little things like if you need a little
pick-me-up or a spruce like updating the
bedding like getting new pillow like
throat hello yeah something like that or
new bath towels or what I found recently
just because this is the first place
that we've actually owned so I could do
this but changing the lighting really
made a really big difference like
putting chandeliers in different places
or like modern like Sputnik type style
things um that like made a big
difference in the way that your you
perceive the room as you're walking into
it you know what I like about Tim's
house is her pantry it's [ __ ] amazing
I can't I am so jealous of your walk-in
pantry and you know what you can use to
fill that pantry
it's probably a lot of healthy foods do
you want you to locate your like
nice-looking pantry with some healthy
foods at an affordable price maybe you
should check out the rive market I've
actually been a subscriber at thrive
market for a few years because back in
2016 um I was starting with my
plant-based cooking and that was kind of
relatively new at the time like I
couldn't find some of the ingredients in
the stores that were around me locally
so I went online and I found thrive
market and they have a bunch of
different ingredients for like all sorts
of different diet types so at the time I
was like trying to eat plant-based and
also trying to eat teto which is almost
impossible but they had these coconut
that um made it so I can make like
avocado egg roll type rolls will open uh
traps and it was very keto friendly and
print plant base um so I started there
and like I continue to really love the
products that they provided and they
they started it because because of that
reason where people wanted to eat
healthier people were on different diets
but a lot of cities in the nation the
word didn't have access to a health food
store like in right around them like so
that you'd have to drive like 30 minutes
to get to your nearest you know Whole
Foods or or sprouts or wherever you went
before so they created this so that you
could actually have access to all of
those ingredients and also at a
discounted rate so it's
subscription-based where you subscribe
and you become a member but then you get
25 to 50% off traditional retail prices
and they're also a carbon neutral
shipping so it's for that it's free on
orders over $49 and not only do I feel
great about getting a deal on my
favorite clean organic products but I
also feel great about helping to support
families who need it the most so in
addition to membership matching private
market is matching donations to their
covered 19 relief fund dollar-for-dollar
which is amazing and this isn't new
either like well it's new to Cove in
nineteen but before that they were doing
that with other you know there are other
charities and other organizations that
they were contributing to so they're a
really great company and in general and
I really like it and they're working
24/7 to make sure members are getting
their groceries delivered as fast as
possible you can learn more about their
commitments customers and membership
matching on their website so try five
market and become a member of risk free
you can go to thrive market calm slash
big mood join today and you'll get up to
twenty dollars in shopping credit
towards your first order that's th our
IDE market.com slash big mood to start
your risk free membership and get up to
$20 toward your first order thrive
market calm slash big mood
yeh nice and healthy
I got another sponsor that I would like
to shout out guys are they societies I
mean no they are it's stitched face
why wouldn't you love every clothing
store you shot that already understood
what you like what you don't like and
what is a hell no so you don't get small
you're on that crap all the time well
there's a company focused on making that
happen
stitch fix is a personal styling company
that brings the world of fashion to you
in a much easier way it's completely
different and fun way to find clothes
that you will love it's all about you
every time to get started you set up a
profile you go through your likes and
dislikes they'll deliver a great
personalized look just for you and the
color styles and budget that you want
you'll pay it $20 styling fee for each
fix but it's credited towards things you
keep also you can schedule for any
number of times that you want you don't
have to do it every single month or you
can do it every single month you can
make a subscription that you want
shipping returns and exchanges are easy
and free so basically they do all the
hard work for you I personally don't
love shopping its it just feels like a
waste of time for me I'd rather buy
things for my house and for my body also
stitch fix has styles for not only women
but men and kids which i think is great
because I know a lot of kids are
probably hard to shop for but you can
probably let them take a little quiz
themselves so yeah get started today at
stitch fix calm slash mood and you'll
get an extra 25% off when you keep
everything in your box
that's stitch fix calm slash mood to get
started stitch fix calm slash mood
middle order Hayley and we all all like
unanimously love the jeans they have
like some special Jean brands that they
particularly send out and it's most
comfortable pair of jeans on track
absolutely but actually was going to
touch on that furniture wise shopping at
the same stores really helped me so I'd
like three may like go to places that I
usually the furniture so I love Urban
Outfitters thing about Urban Outfitters
also aesthetically I love Urban
Outfitters home is their Instagram it's
not every urban outfitter store that
carries the furniture items
online but I love looking through their
home section they always have sales
going on I get a lot of accent pieces
for them and also furniture items I love
the aesthetic I will say that it's kind
of hit or miss on the quality like
whether like some people get it and it
starts falling apart immediately I've
been pretty lucky with the pieces that
I've gotten they didn't they didn't fall
apart um but I I do have like this one
couch that the like lining on it started
to fall off but that was after like a
year or so but anyway I find going
shopping at the same stores all the time
they tend to have similar style products
so you play throughout the year and you
could probably match the aesthetic that
you already have in your house I love
Urban Outfitters I also love if you want
deals there's a place called Joss and
main online but it's an I use their app
but they have deals all the time kind of
like Wayfarer and um what's it called
overstocked it's kind of way for an
overstock never have like really really
cheap prices but a lot of times I don't
love their aesthetic of their step so
Josten main kind of like has a
mid-century modern type of feel but then
like more affordable prices by the way
not sponsored at all I just like yeah
these are not sponsor I wouldn't tell
you this day is like shitty promise but
yeah those two places and then if you
have more of a budget West Elm or Lulu
at Lulu and Georgia are really nice
places to go oh and for rugs you know
it's [ __ ] so hard to find rugs that
are like budget-friendly because you're
like I'm gonna want to spend $2,000 on a
[ __ ] 8 by 5 rug okay so rugs USA girl
where are you shopping for rugs rugs was
a nice so weird oh my god no I don't
shop at the two thousand dollar places
but I know let's spend like money for
room and I'm like this is insane
rugs is the last thing I've been saving
in my place I bought one rug from
ruggable you seen the ads on Instagram
we're like you can remove it and throw
it in the washer machine no only reason
I got it well I'm like I need to find
out what the hell this thing ever I
swear to god though it rugs us a [ __ ]
check it out I would not lie to you okay
I feel like a man I get alerts on Amazon
is it better than though okay yeah so
it's like I don't know how they offer
these prices so cheap for the quality of
they get I should be paid for this solid
and they're big like for the price that
it is like they're all under like the
bigger ones were like $100 that I got
and they were like wow and by 13 which
was yeah that's yeah it's illegal I
think that's illegal for the bigger ones
but like the other one yeah we're like
$100 and I think I think it was like 200
or something for a 5x7 the one I have
here and yeah that sounds about right
like [ __ ] it it's machine washable
because I didn't want to stain our
actual like carpet yeah people they were
they were like why would you put a rug
over carpet I'm like to protect a great
yeah thank you for high-traffic areas
also aesthetically I just like the way
rug like area rugs look and bumpy
otherwise you're supposed to separate
your areas with area rugs so you can go
[ __ ] yourself if you have a problem go
[ __ ] yourself you know like a rug okay
could we take maybe a few minutes and
talk about style that's like really bad
yes I remember I remember going to like
some over to like some guy's house like
I've been dating like over the guys I
mean yeah and so like minute I I want to
say I want to say okay guys don't ever
buy a black leather couch that's like
that has no structure to it you know
that's only my god
ever buy a black leather couch unless
it's like a $5,000 you guys think that's
so dope they think it's so cool but see
it's like a we're against how she's ever
had it's like American Psycho like
there's this there's this kind of like
weird almost like style that some guys
pick up that's like kind of corporate
but like they're trying to be cool or
something it just it's creepy especially
if it's in your bachelor pad where a
black eye which doesn't match your one
bedroom studio [ __ ] like light pine
wood fake laminate flooring it doesn't
matter okay yeah and I'm like are they
just doing like the casting couch thing
isn't that why they think okay kinda
looks like that I don't know I don't
know if they're doing it on purpose but
it looks really bad and they're not huge
big black bulky like plywood on oh no
you know like an entertainment center
that's like yes bulky and it's yeah
particle board and it's that black
particle board it just looks so trashy
I'm like you're taking up too much space
it's like very cluttered and clunky and
it's ugly
here's my theory is that they see like a
loft style dope-ass looking you know
leather like it looks like a freaky
mixology bar in there you know it's like
ice ceilings and like downtown loft
quarter window like like oh I'm gonna
make my [ __ ] bachelor pad look like
that and they don't take into account
that their actual space doesn't look
like that so they say like in the store
and like maybe it has like it's
surrounded by similar aesthetic you know
when you go to like Z Gallerie and it's
like surrounded by the same the tables
that match and all the fun yeah and so
then they're like oh dope like I love
this couch and then they put it in their
shitty card - dude like right on
apartment that has like [ __ ] barely
seven foot ceilings
yeah and then they're like it must look
dope I think their eyeballs just look at
the item that they bought yeah those
guys go get latest beyond me how I still
have sex with those guys is beyond me
it's no beyond me desperate desperate
time
and then like the same thing with the
[ __ ] entertainment center that you're
talking about I think they just see it
in the store the stores are big you know
yeah that clunky and they don't have
like one ratty towel you know like
there's that you have to do to make your
apartment feel like comfortable even if
it if it's not feminine you know you
don't have to have a feminine place if
you're a dude but like if you pay a
little bit of attention to style and
like having maybe different textures or
like maybe have one throw blanket or
whatever on the couch you know just
certain things that make it not feel so
barren and creamy and like gross you
know like I don't know need some like
dishes yeah when I first moved in the
scene I don't know how he got me if I
hadn't known him beforehand like dude he
had an air mattress as a bed no joke
he had a frickin air my dad a futon no
no cheats' he just said he had you know
those fleece blankets that you like as a
throw on the couch you know like that he
was living like a home away Kid it looks
like American Psycho like because it was
girl there was the black sofa but it was
way too big for his living room and then
he had like a clunky STD that you know
before there were flat screens the you
know high tech TVs were like can you buy
more yes he bought that TV it was like
his first major purchase and he bought
the TV in 2005 at a Black Friday sale
and he stood in lying at like 5 a.m. and
in his mind because it was like the top
of the line in 2005 in 2013 when we were
dating he was still top of the line it
literally took up half the living room
because he had like a clean like was it
like clutter like it was not because
there were no items there were no I'm
just yeah I deal with Audi yeah I'd
rather deal with that and I don't know
how [ __ ] married the dude but his
place was disgusting
so bad so he had he lived with the
roommate and then he had lived with his
ex-girlfriend and this ex-girlfriend
apparently was like the biggest slob
ever like the most disgusting human ever
because I like you couldn't even walk
into the kitchen because it was [ __ ]
everywhere and then in his bedroom it
was all of her [ __ ] two girls like it
she didn't even live there anymore I'm
like oh how I was so confused and the
she thing he had were gross remember um
you gotta watch the watch the love is
blind you know which love is blind
okay so there's a guy named Mark he's 24
and he's paired up with Jessica I don't
know part of the girl of his line but
like everyone hated Jessica she was like
the villain character anyway it's just
blonde - yeah she was but she yes she
called him for this other guy and so she
was just like with this 24-year old dude
and she made a big deal out of their age
difference but when and it was like kind
of like petty throughout the whole show
until you go to his house and he lives
like a 24 year old like he has roommates
and then his room is she made a big deal
about how all the sheets are brown so on
point like a guy before dating like a
woman or like that the feminine touch
why do they have brown sheet but such a
good sheets were supposed to be white
and they were [ __ ] they were browning
or if they worried if they weren't
originally black and they're just so old
and like yeah the Sun bleachers are like
falling on heart I'm like in the pillows
like he was with I'm like how did a girl
live here is so composed oh my oh this
is so nasty
and it was gross there was old food
everywhere like Oh dams nasty illegally
friends high school but not since moving
out I've never done like that that's
crazy
neither have I I can't live like that I
think I just didn't have a sense of
ownership when I lived at my parents
house especially like yeah with all the
rules and stuff that I just like it
reflected in my environment cuz I felt
like this isn't none of this is mine
like really mine I never felt like
everything anything was mine and then
when I moved out it was like oh my gosh
I own this and there was like a sense of
pride of decorating it and like living
there and taking care of it stuff and
that's really racy I've always felt like
my room was mine even in my dad's house
and my dad too like the way I grew up
like we always had to rent because we
were poor but like every time we rented
a new space my dad was very handy he
would fix things that were broken he
would basically return the house to them
in a better condition than we got the
house ready dollars and so we always
took ownership of even rentals and even
while he made me feel like my room was
my [ __ ] too so I definitely got to
decorate everything the way I wanted to
and I loved that I hate hearing that
people that never really felt like their
space in their parents houses there's I
think of another big part of it it was
until I was 13 so from all the entire
childhood up through 13 a teenager I had
to share a room with my brother it was
like a bunk bed and like it wasn't I
couldn't like make it girly cuz yeah
there too and then also like it was also
it was weird too because as I went
through puberty and then living like a
date having a boy sharing a room with me
it was it was odd but then yeah that's
when my parents bought a house and um
then we each got our own rooms it was
like right in the nick of time was like
right all those I'm a teenager but yeah
so I think because growing up I share my
room with the boy the entire time by the
time I got my own room I just didn't
even like the girliest thing I did was
put up lights like little string lights
got it and then everything else with um
and posters oh my gosh yeah I had a ton
of posters in my room - always I don't
know what interior design style
called but I dug it cold M&Ms yes I was
only able to decorate the space that I
had based off of whatever was given to
me like I never had the option to
actually pick anything out for my room
it's like Animal Crossing it really is
like right off the blade and I'm like I
like dude I [ __ ] hate my house it
looks like I don't like whatever I don't
like a type sight this is the only thing
that they have and then I hate that you
can't shop for everything yet like it's
yeah like every date whatever anyway
what about every conversation turns into
animal crossing with you two previous
video Lee I know cuz the previous videos
I'll just be like yeah no I see you've
got it it's so addicting see you know
what else was interesting tip was a from
me what we took a master class together
on interior design so if you're having
trouble like getting inspired or you
don't know this exactly like one thing I
thought was interesting was like using
your fashion items or like things that
you want on your clothes like that to
inspire your yeah
to inspire your home aesthetic so like
different jewelry pieces that you like
you could find like pieces that kind of
look like that or like that whatever
color you're drawn to that you see
yourself wearing a lot like if you just
look at your wardrobe and then like you
pick out your favorite outfit then she
recommends like you know you can start a
place from there like that point and she
actually has does interior designed a
lot of spaces based off of like because
she likes to correct collect a lot of
like crystals and stuff and like she'll
get like certain crystals at like she
really loves and then she'll like do an
entire like Lobby hotel lobby base off
of it or whatever but that was a really
good tip that I never considered either
it's like just looking at what you
already have everyone makes their own
decisions already mm-hm and in terms of
their aesthetic whether it be their
wardrobe or their living space or even
like if you're in high school and I mean
I don't know high school kids still do
this but you know the binder is like you
know we use
I know I down they still do that these
days but they don't know iPad yeah I
know but like or whatever like [ __ ] that
you're following her I don't know but
yeah it's just then you can find
inspiration anywhere and you can
literally go from there so that's the
guy I want I want to give even if it's
just guys or girls who really have zero
clue where to start because I was never
really that girly of a girl like this is
my first time having like something I'm
proud of so can we just give like maybe
five top things to do because I know you
mentioned lighting and plants like oh
yeah like a couple other things like
just just to start off that will
absolutely make your space better and
click start a run go ahead what I like
for sure a rug I think a helpful thing
too if you're starting if you starting
from nothing like you just don't even
know her site is like making everything
neutral and then adding like one or two
accent colors so everything is are those
accent colors yeah she's actually what I
did with my previous living room and
that thing easiest way to that's heal
gray like wood whatever but yeah the
good starting place I think mine is took
consider different textures because I
was always very scared of textures so
like now I have a throw blanket that's
super furry whereas I'm not a girl that
usually has a lot of furry [ __ ] but I
was like there's a lot of there's like I
have a very masculine couch so I
balanced that by having like a like a
super almost like a Sherpa furry type of
throw blanket so just consider mixing in
textures that you might normally think
oh I don't know cuz it's actually gonna
make a big difference
oh yeah I like that tip like metals like
the masculine feminine balance medicine
that's super super helpful because for
me when I'm are you gonna I was gonna
that basically reiterate the same things
go ahead oh no but like for me another
major gigantic huge factor is like price
point like I'm I'm really [ __ ] cheap
and it's really
for me to spend a lot of money on like
it's like except the base house like
this house was like okay I gotta stop
being so cheap but I've always lived by
like IKEA stuff or like I don't know the
my go-to place to get accents like
little knickknacks and stuff has always
been home goods or Marshalls or
sometimes because it's good like it's
good quality stuff but and it's at a way
discounted price than you would get like
Ali market or whatever yeah the markets
are good too but yeah it's like really
balancing your wallet is really hard
when you're trying I like make its
honestly plants to like I'm a big fake
plant person because I don't like taking
care of plants I don't think you're a
very natural plant person okay I like
fake plants and I got a [ __ ] on fake
plants at Hobby Lobby Hobby Lobby is
really good prices for fake plants like
this is a big plant a taquito
oh so it's a planner and it looks like a
plant where's the cow let's take a [ __ ]
up its behind it and look through the
corner behind here oh so they around it
and they [ __ ] yeah there's a hold and
they let them in and this is the color
of kitty litter I am impressed very
impressed when I lived in a studio
apartment we're like the living room a
bedroom or one and it's like where do
you put a kitty litter that's what I
bought that
okay everyone can buy the town yeah also
just be careful right that's true that's
true you have to like it um I want to
emphasize throw pillows because they
make a huge difference to your bed your
couch your anywhere that you're like
something this looks less like when
you're like talking about textures throw
pillar is really help and throw pillows
can get expensive so what tip was
talking about like well yeah they're
opposed to be nice but like how are you
doing on the budget hot tip um amazon
has like throw pillow covers so you have
pillows once or like you can buy a
really cheap like IKEA ones like where
there just has a square stuffing and
then you just change out the pillow
covers yeah and bucks yeah
tend to like four of them yeah I got
like a pack of books I will say I did
get a pack in for my
before and the quality was so bad really
not match yeah you have to be diligent
about the ones at my bedroom are from
Amazon I like it yeah hit Omega I got my
outdoor ones been in there Oh anyway
that hour flew by I hope you guys got
some good tips from this episode if you
have anything else that you guys want us
to talk about something helpful that
would help you during either during
quarantine or during life in general
like let us know well like if we've
talked about it before these are all
like things that we've talked about in
our group chat so I feel like if you
help us it can help you so let us know
also thank you to all of our sponsors
shout out to them and subscribe rate us
on iTunes if you're listening on itunes
and you know we love you guys
so we will see you next time yes bye
guys